don't worry i'll keep you secure yeah
well if he's gonna say one of my
brothers are trying to attack you
oh no no no no okay no look the thing is
very casual yesterday we want to go this
way they know about it yeah yes okay the
video's not even out yeah look we went
there to have a discussion
yeah but the point is this year we need
to understand brothers and sisters here
this that is anti-semitic future that
nobody can come and see because we know
they're using the whole narrative of if
you talk against israel and symmetra i
don't buy that
i don't think you guys will buy it
because it's good it's as good as and
you might disagree with me
it's as good as isis coming and seeing
your islamic folk for talking against us
that's why i believe
so the first thing is this yeah any
thunks i'm telling you well now don't
give you're a muslim i don't give a damn
if you think you're brave enough to come
and two people who come to the park
regularly where we have nice discussions
i don't even let me tell you even if the
pro is is ready we will have an
intellectual discussion so i want to
make that very categorically clear
anyone that gets resourced to violence
against anybody
you're a weak individual and this is
what you have to do can i add to that as
well
can i add to that this is very important
okay this is extremely important
the the way you need to deal with people
in life
okay the quran says
whoever tries to seek retribution for
after they have been oppressed
there's no there's no there's no blame
on them okay
but what i want to say is that means to
say that if anyone
guys please please if listen if someone
is coming to you with positive
and energy right and they are
not trying to do anything to you by
virtue of the fact that they're jewish
now you will start to be aggressive
towards them then what's the difference
between
what we are condemning and what you are
becoming
this is my question what is the
difference between what we are
condemning and what you are becoming
because most of the time we become what
we condemn
you know and this is a psychoanalytic
situation you know someone gets bullied
they become
the bully we can't afford to be like
that
with jewish people and muslim people we
have had
a beautiful history i don't know what
your views are on the history of isla of
judaism and islam
but sir michael gilbert and others even
bernard lewis who is an audiences
has has rated the jewish experience
in muslim lands the point being is this
the conflation
that is being made between zionism
and judaism is a dangerous conflation
and if the muslim community make that
conflation
and as a result of it start to baja
and to attack and to try and cause
intolerance to the jewish community
believe you me you have not only
betrayed yourselves
but you have betrayed the prophet
muhammad and you have betrayed islam
because this is not the way he used to
act at all even and you know let me tell
you something else you know that most of
your brothers are like that most of the
brothers come to the park yeah
we talk and we converse normally no but
i want to say this even if one of them
if i get news or if ali gets news
or if hersham gets news on one sword any
of us get news
that there are muslims in this park that
are causing
people like aaron rabbi aaron and rabbi
yoel no
rabbi okay no problem he's being humble
he's being humble
it's pleasure no no i'm telling you this
these police these useless
officers here that come into the car
that come into the park at 40 miles an
hour and run over children
almost honestly he ran it almost run
over a child this fools
they are not going to be the ones who
are going to have words with you let's
say
it's going to be us that have words with
you as the muslim community
we will have words with you and we will
boycott you and we will embarrass you
and we will not honestly because you
just want them to just if any of you
guys are here
and you see hostility is upon you to
defend them yeah okay it's up on you
because i would feel the same but if i'm
in a jewish community like we went to
golden screen yesterday okay
it got a little bit hostile some remarks
were made okay i would expect
and i'm sure if you guys were there
thank you if you was there you would
have said
hold on a second here even whatever it
may be so brother and sister is very
important since you got out of the way
are you satisfied
solely
let me tell you something i could make a
few new jokes and stuff like that but i
promise do you want to i promise you
i am not saying these words because of
cameras here and to make it so
i swear to god i am saying this because
i genuinely believe and if i was here
i would be on your side i'll make it
very clear now coming and
and on that sorry yeah just to add it no
you never interrupt me okay
the prophet muhammad
give victory to your brother meaning the
muslim brother whether they are the
oppressive
or the oppressor and they said how would
you how would you um
how would you uh give victory to someone
who's the oppressor he said that by
stopping the oppression
so listen the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam had very
very cordial relationships with jewish
people well
even after wars took place even when the
jewish man died even after
wars took place and whilst wars were
taking place
he would have cordial relationships with
them
never and i'm saying this now confused
or a combatant and you know advocate for
the
science movement some hostile person
with
a jewish if we see that you do that and
i'm saying this again we will be the
first ones to be against you
no young person here can ever look at a
jewish person say this
let's go get what do you mean you
wouldn't be doing that if you knew that
he would
if they had something on them if they're
if they were not outnumbered
don't act cowardly this is cowardice
yeah where do you think this all this
hatred is coming from obviously there's
a source to it
all around the world yeah where do you
think this um we'll come to this one
but i wanted to engage with them yeah
exactly yes exactly
yeah we're gonna answer your question
we'll have questions what we want to do
with
the interview so the question on the
matter of israel and palestine yes
because look even if you're pro
we want to have a discussion so hijab
because this is
let's start with the job i want to ask
you just what discussion with your with
your
we're going to make it fast because the
simple thing is
i spoke to the chef before i said the
main point is we have to speak to each
other
and not about each other and not focus
on the media and focus as i said
to youtube all our followers because
then you have the full comments and
everyone
badging their own side or on twitter you
just talk about yourself
as long as we speak to each other we
talk to each other when you hear the
other side
then we agree far more than we do oh we
can do this here
they will not do it they will not be
doing it over there right now okay for
obvious reasons
this this is our you know what we're
looking at here
could be something which changes
societal momentum
across the world because we have to
bring back a state of normality
and peace honestly i'm not just saying
that fall as lip service i mean this
because
based on how this conversation goes
honestly it can make a difference
between life and death
someone some zionist or some terrorist
or whatever maybe
might get angered and aroused and then
start doing something which in the name
of judaism or zionism or islam whatever
it is that will will take us 10 years
back so what i'm saying is i just want
to ask you now
what is your view on the issues
uh just generally oh open question open
question is simple
condemn violence condemn death and it
should hurt
me and you for every innocent person or
even a combatant
because they only combatant because they
see no future they don't understand the
other side they don't understand each
other
and if they would only talk and find a
way to work each other's problems out
and understand each other's aspirations
then as we have spoken many times in the
past we understand each other and see
how much we would really agree
and i'll take it a step further i think
that the fact that
there is this belief in the world that
jews and muslims can't get along
is an imperialistic thing from
colonialist power like britain
who brought it to us to believe that
dividing and conquering people
is the way forward do you believe do you
agree then that
as the u.n uh says and human rights
watch and all of these organizations
that
the actions of the israeli government
have not only been disproportionate
but they have been catastrophic for the
people of gaza and they have been
unwarranted
in the sense that the damage that has
been done
has has been something which really
can't be undone
and unfortunately has caused more
problems in the middle east
in that area to what extent would you
agree with there's a lot of questions in
this one
there's a lot of questions to to get to
put together
right the simple concept is if we're
going to talk about
the what's happening now without going
into the reason course behind it
then it is yes to look at the current
form if you're going to look simply at
numbers are you going to look at the
reason
then yes it is something that is bad we
know it wants a house blown up no one
wants even a dog hurt in the side not in
gaza not in jerusalem not in alcott
no way definitely everyone would agree
with that so
but if you're going to go back and we're
going to take it a step backwards and
we're going to just go
first take facts and let's work with
that and work your way forward
and then work on our aspirations to
understand the two aspirations of two
people
right so i believe that these two people
could live together maybe in two states
or even one state
okay let's get let's talk about facts
right because the facts
are that 25 days before hamas even
launched a rocket
25 days before that happened al-aqsa
compound was
stormed and vice news has done a very
good piece on this you can watch it's a
20 minute piece
and in that they show that actually
al-aqsa was stormed
there was bullets being fired tear gas
being shot
people were being dispersing you see
women bleeding okay
and of course you have shaykh as well is
and this is very important to understand
according to the un
this whole east jerusalem area is not
under israeli uh it's not part of israel
for all intents and purposes
now my point is this is why is it that
you talk about reasons
for me the reasons are very clear is
provocation just like you know there's
the wailing wall and
other sacred sites and stuff like that
for jews
there also is and so on in east
jerusalem
i agree so would you not agree here that
the continued the continued situation
yeah perpetuation of problems in that
area with the cells
in the holy month but not only that it's
the settlements issue this is the issue
the settlements issue
you know it's you're not i'm not you of
course but israel so-called israel
because i don't agree with what they
consider themselves as to be honest with
you
they consider themselves as something
that we as the international community
completely they have all their own
definition what the country is which no
one else agrees with quite quite frankly
that israel have been doing in terms of
settlements in the area
not just in chicago in all of the areas
which they are not entitled to put
settlements in
okay in the west bank all of that area
that is
the heart of the problem if that did not
exist okay
then there could have been a discussion
about potentially two-state solutions
but like
yeah it always depends at which point we
roll back and circle back
to yes yes you can circle back to point
a
and then you can set it back to point b
point c a and depends how far you circle
back
to what you're going to see on the full
picture on the full image right
so what do you have to remember
something as follows right designs
in israel yes they don't see themselves
as oppressors i'm talking from their
perspective if you're going to meet the
zionists they're not going to see
themselves as oppressors
you can see yourself as violence i don't
see myself as a zionism
it depends it depends again what the
definition of zionism is right and
somebody else before before
his brother what what do i believe in
you say free palestine what the word
free palestine mean
is it is it an anti-semitic inverse so
it's term or not
so explaining it depends as well what
the term
means to entitle which part of it so it
always depends how far you're going to
circle okay
that means is the fact is with the
united nations
with britain with the baffler
declaration with all of it they've put
two people against each other
that's the simple fact then there you
have the ngos
the non-profit organizations that come
to serve at calls and the end the course
comes to serve themselves
and the one who gained the most are the
politicians
the ngos the media they're the one who
gained the most
who loses the most are the simple
brothers and sisters on both sides okay
children and yeah and and women and
never mind your children
simple adults are the ones who suffer
but you know i'm so sorry you know what
it is yesterday when we went to go to
screen here
and we had a van we hired a van and we
were just showing images of what's
happening here
um and to me look it's it's it be
israeli kids or not
but we came across a very disturbing
comment which was like
one of the the people that said that
they bought it on themselves
yeah so one of one guy said that today i
think sorry but you see you're seeing
something over here
and we went there we didn't go there to
be hostile police came in like
it's like it's like they were there but
they just vanished and
appeared in two seconds and they came
and the thing is
brother you know that it's a charge time
yes so yeah
people who don't know you and don't know
muhammad yeah and he looks
quite intimidating even if we know that
he's a cuddly babe
but they then people people always go on
their fences that's
that's the nature
the automatic charge that you have in
society today is the fact it's been
after
the car that that that drove past the
car and they drove past
and started what they sheltered at that
i always say is it's not easy even
without all these people
and show those pictures in this
particular location
we did a public one and then we did it i
agree and we did one with the jewish
people and that's why i would condemn
anyone on any side but they didn't just
says you know you know i know and that's
one thing i condem
anyone on any side who makes
who makes who makes you trivial or or
anything about you know about children
women anyone at all
and that i would agree one hundred
dollars this is what i'm saying we went
there too because i want to be back i'll
tell you why i have this tone because
we haven't met each other and we know
that okay we come and feed
but we want to get back to the point
because otherwise we're going to do
he was probably pointing out the fact
that a lot of times there are pictures
of circulation
yeah there are pictures from many years
ago or from different locations that are
being circulated on social media
or even by prominent people but he's
these children
which are just he knows
and are there to intentionally create
misinformation okay but if people
had certainly if you had a van where if
if it is
excuse me because it's important
for the interview
this way all those people i can't say
all of them
uh sorry aaron look let's not be around
the bush there's clearly
there is clearly an anti-arab sentiment
in israel
as there may be a very clear
anti-semitic
sentiment in the arab world right now
do you agree with a two-state solution
you think that palestinians would want
and accept an israeli state their belief
i don't think it's true their belief
would be
no they don't and they would back it up
with simple arguments as follows
they would say is that that from the
creation of the state of israel for
example
in 1948
in 1948 from the creation of the state
of israel
when the west bank was under the judean
control and when they
were and when gaza was on the egyptian
control
the palestinians never claimed being a
press under the rule of those two
countries
these are assertions though no i'm just
saying what
yeah i'm just giving you the concept
where they come from i'm not saying it's
true
and just giving you the background from
the way they see it the next thing they
see is
that when you go when the palestinians
start shouting they see something said
from the river to the sea
palestine will be free so the way they
view it and they back it up
with the chapter for example from hamas
that the palestinians
do not want a jewish state in any shape
or form
now so when they asked me it's free
palestine yeah a palestinian calls an
anti-semitic call when you ask me before
one of your brothers
i told them it depends what it means
okay it means a palestinian state
then sure there should be a palestinian
okay oh
guys i want to say free palestine guys
guys we have we're having a discussion
all right cool okay and then if you're
gonna ask me nothing
okay and i have given you the chance to
do that okay listen
you've you've said you've talked about
the balfour declaration then you talk
about you've alluded to the 48 war and
the 67
borders all right you've alluded to
those things let me be very
straightforward here
let's talk about the facts first and
foremost when the balfour declaration
took place
it was one country promising to a second
country the land of a third country
now under any world view i'm sure in
judaism
or in um islam or liberalism no no no
let me finish let me finish because i've
let you speak for five minutes
look the fact is chain wiseman and other
members of the
uh zionist move yeah sorry chaim wiseman
and other members of the
zionist group we're saying in english
right
okay listen please i've let you i've let
you spoke to speak so
just try and listen to me for a bit yeah
crime wiseman
and other members of the zionist
movement in this country when they sent
letters
all right to british authorities and
then there was the balfour declaration
it was just that one country
promising a second people the land of
the third people
and what's important at this point is to
realize that british
the the british did not have a mandate
in palestine at this time
the mandate the mandate in palestine
started two years afterwards okay
so this was the ottoman empire so it's
now britain talking about how
they're going to manage parts of the
ottoman empire this isn't
by all intents and purposes not even
colonial this is this is hyper
colonialism you're talking about a
country you don't even have under your
colonial control
and yours promising that country which
you don't even have in your colonial
control the
to another people you see i don't see
how in any way shape or form anyone can
justify
well this is somewhat legitimizes the
state of israel
and if you look at a book for example
the struggle for
palestine written by a jew herod's hurts
it's a classic book on this topic
you'll see in the 30s what happened okay
in the 30s what happened is that there
was a
immigration of the jewish population
into what is
what is called israel today uh and
obviously
it was a palestine area this was uh
from people in russia people in jews in
russia 40 000 people
went into palestine okay now you imagine
this mass population
of a country uh which can't actually
cope with that
which start which sparked something
called in 1936 the arab
revolt 1939 you had the white paper okay
and then you had terrorist activity we
talked about hamas
but let's not forget that you had
terrorist activity by the urgon
and by the hagen and by levi and that
terrorist activity
was rewarded by the british empire which
in 1946 culminated of course in the king
david hotel bombing
which was the targeting of civilians
after the after the resolution in 1947
by the un
1948 may the 13th i think it was
israel became what it is today now i
don't know why it would be
against morality or against liberalism
or against your worldview or my
worldview to say actually
the way in which your state came into
being
was established was completely immoral
in every single way
shape or form the only thing you guys
really have to say about that
is that well we have a we were there in
70 a.d
no you weren't they weren't there okay
just calm down for a second please
please
please bro please if okay you were there
70 a.d there was a siege
of jerusalem very well known hebron the
king and so on now we talk about ancient
history
here the normans were you know we always
talk about hastings let's talk about the
fact that the romans were here
okay there was the gaelic what they call
it the gaelic wars whatever
in before christ so some italian guy
comes and says we're roman we have
rights to britain this is the ridiculous
nature of the claim no one makes these
you have to understand guys
no one makes these claims except for
zionists understand that no one
legitimizes okay
the the the status of a state based on
the fact that there's archaeological
evidence from a thousand four hundred
five six thousand years ago whatever it
was
three thousand years ago two thousand
whatever it was yeah no one does that
now you guys are doing that that's very
well good
but the point is you have to understand
this is for all intents and purposes
it's a catastrophic yes oppressive way
in which estate has been established
i've made this example before i'll say
again
if isis and i'm going to make an even
more inflammatory comment today
i'm going to make a very inflammatory
controversial i want you to react to it
the way that isis conquered land which
is monstrous and condemnable
and diabolical and megalomaniacal and
unacceptable
like the adjectives yes no just so that
there's no it's
no complication i'm saying what i'm
saying right the way that they
established land in the times that they
did
was more noble even though it's
ridiculous than the way you did it
do you know why not you but the way
designers did you know why because at
least they fought for it themselves
the the zionists relied on the fighting
of
of the british empire with all due
respect you needed
american backing the u.n backing you
needed
i i think that sorry israel is a bastard
state
and what i mean by that it doesn't have
a father in fact it's a product of one
night stand of the un
and the british empire the israel does
not happen
no please let me finish please please
please bro please let me
let me let me just let me finish let me
finish the po
is a bastard state okay i'm being very
straightforward i don't want to give you
two faces and lie to you
why on earth should we we should appease
this oh
you should have the 1967 borders who
said after the second world war
that you're allowed to conquer
territories who said that you guys are
part of the un
yes israel is part of the u.n who said
who
on earth said you're now allowed to
conquer territories so
the fact that the 1967 borders of what
is being referred to
implies that the new world order
including america is willing to
acquiesce
to states and territories being
conquered conquered which is the same as
what isis have done
sorry to say but like i say it's less
noble it's less it's more ignorable you
know why
because isis with all their monstrous
and diabolical uh
actions they fought themselves whereas
you well not you but
the israelis had they needed the uan and
the uni
the u.s cowards i'm sorry the way that
they established themselves is
completely cowardly i'm not going to be
around the bush and pretend to be civil
here we don't need to we don't need to
pretend oh two-state solution
do you think for me to say i actually
believe that
the the the uh the way in which israel
established itself
in the first place is completely
oppressive and illegitimate you think
that makes me an anti-semite
if that makes me an anti-semite i'm
happy to be labeled as such
exactly good point but if this is your
definition of anthemicism
if the definition of anti-semitism has
become that i can't even condemn
the the way a conquering state yeah
becomes a country that i'm ready to be
called an anti-semite but the truth is i
am a sea mate myself
brother how are you going to be brother
please make me please please people
ain't i
i know i know i must seem like myself
right and even by the way i've done the
ancestry test
and i had some jewish in me it's my to
my surprise
and by the way when i went to gold is
green and i told them that they started
uh having a different uh attitude to be
all together
i was talking about these things bro you
know and then afterwards i said you know
i had
done an ancestry test and i had some
jewish in me they're like oh
i saw the smiles on their faces and
honestly this is the thing before you go
i know i spoke for a long time i'm going
to let you be back but please bro
i'm just saying this this this um this
pathetic
use of the word anti-semitism as a
deflection mechanism
of the covert narcissistic state which
uses a scapegoat
these these labels and these terms oh
it's anti-semitic if you talk about
israel it's ant symmetric if you talk
about the history of israel
if you don't agree with the two-state
solution the way we like it this 1967
borders who told you that
if that's what anti-semitism is then
everyone is an anti-semite and we don't
mind being labeled as such but that's
not what anti-muslim
semitism is but what anti-semitism is is
when you discriminate against someone
hatred of jews because of their
jewishness
that's what if you look at the
dictionary that's what it says no one is
saying that jews shouldn't have a
homeland
we're just saying don't make your
on the expense of someone else's
homeland don't what we're saying
just jacob this pathetic that fat slob
you know in in in in in saying if you if
i don't steal it someone else is going
to steal it
i put the middle finger up to him and to
his state i put the middle finger up to
him into his state and say you know what
if you're talking about stealing like
that
you know i to be honest with you we
don't give a damn about
if being labeled as anti-semitic
we don't give a damn about we have to
understand aaron wallahi
the only way you understand how we feel
if you
go back down memory lane you realize
everything was oppressive
everything was oppressive from 1917
onwards every single thing
you have no right to speak about
anything honestly everything was
bad then everything was bad from from
balfour declaration
all those things are not points for you
they're against you so how much did they
want to see the
examination of jews or that they want to
see all muslims in an area
who said that we agree with hamas on
every point of the
the charter of hamas has become the
quran who said that
i tell you something under the ottoman
empire jewish people
and you know this you will agree with
this
yeah they have been they were actually
fleeing from the from the christian west
after the inquisition in 1492 they were
fleeing running away
to the muslims where they had their
golden error we say this we say we
believe in coexistence
but we believe in coexistence not at our
expense
never at our expense coexistence doesn't
mean you come into my house
and say that if i don't steal it someone
else is going to steal it we put the
middle finger up
to people that say that or in in the way
that you do it sorry this is very rude
the way you do it in your country we do
this as well yeah we do that to them you
know that
if we do this one we do that one and
that one
well i we don't agree with any of this
bull bs
we don't accept it we cannot accept it
and this discourse is a
is a sham it's a sham it is a sham
it's not a level playing field like two
sizes as there's a clear oppressor
and oppressed as normal fingersteen says
there's a raper and the rapist
if the rapist after getting what he
wants he's starting the rape
the raped one gets up and spits he said
this i spoke to him
he said this is online he said if he
spits at the rapper and says you know
he deserves to be spat don't tell him oh
you why did you spit at him we need to
go back and circle back in history
come on let's be honest the truth of the
matter is this
this has been the only time for a very
long time
since i don't know 280 or something
where the jews have actually have a
chance
and the zionists just say to show us how
it would look like if you had a state
where they were in control and
unfortunately
they're not doing a good job of it at
all what they're showing us is that it's
the worst
time in history okay probably
with the exception of the crusades in
the last 2000 years
that there's been such oppression
bombing children let's not pretend i'll
be you know
yeah of course i can't outdo you i think
it's around for prime minister in this
place
i'm gonna run for prime minister i'll
vote for you i'm going to run for prime
minister
in israel i'm going to be there am i
with you
as well
listen to me i'm going to do it fast and
i'm going to go into detail i'm just
going to answer a few of your points
that you made
you mentioned that the british but above
the declaration weren't on the british
mandate in palestine it was still the
ottoman empire
yes that's correct that's the point i
always say the british the colonies
free the state of israel before they
even control the area
yes already was interested in splitting
two people apart yes
that's number one so the colonialists
who had this vision of breaking two
people's
a bond that we've had for thousands of
years we're the colonies british
that's fact number one fact number two
is when we talk about the colonial
bricks
occupied the area of palestine
and those times which people kicked the
colonists
out were the terrorist jewish
organizations that's the
that's the fact as you mentioned before
i cannot excellently these three
organizations
kick the colonial british out of the
area
that is called palestine what you mean
to say is that they committed terrorist
attacks
against the colonial power no no they
killed civilians all right so let's be
honest
nineteen fourteen i'm not justifying it
good good no way at all i'm just right
in the fact of
who can take the colonists out of that
area no no let's let's
let's be honest okay let me let me
challenge you before please don't run
please are we hiding uh we've had enough
of people running away from conversation
i know i know i don't know why you keep
saying you know it right no because he
has to go through
i'm not using the word run okay let me
tell you this very carefully
let me let me say something listen
carefully
no no no but let's just finish the
conversation listen bro okay listen
begin okay who was part of it
thank you okay who is part of the ergon
okay he became the president of the
country the premier sorry the prime
minister from
from years 1977 to 1981 correct i've
done it exactly yes
okay look he became the prime the
president of the prime minister of the
country my country don't forget all
right
he became the prime minister of the
listen i want i want people to really
think about this for a second okay
he became the prime minister of the
country okay from 1977 to 1981
and he was one of the perpetrators of
the bombing on civilians in a hotel
now i want to put this king david hotel
1946 right now i want to say i want to
put you this way
you have someone who's a terrorist from
the muslim community
he leads a group of terrorists and he
goes to a hotel let's say the hilton
hotel
blows himself up shoots some some people
some
people are going up to the hotels maybe
they're getting a robe they go
downstairs to get the buffet you know
what i'm trying to say you want to get a
breakfast and then you know what you get
some guy terrorists shoot you in the
head
okay how can they move of course you can
do that
good but but i'm just telling you the
point of trying to bring a different
point completely
not about the terror attacks where we
condemn it and as we've said before even
is evil no matter who perpetrates it now
what i'm saying is
kicking them out this is not kicking
them out this is the british empire
and the un rewarding a terrorist
organization for their terrorism that's
what it is
that's why it's happening yes i'll take
it to the next step yeah yeah there are
many people who say that the
that the muslim calls the way to fight
for palestine is
are you comparing someone trying to
bring your point is to do
the same thing that the that hagan did
against the british to do that against
the it's really the same
and then they will just do what the
british did they made a calculated
a calculated um what's called the
equation the price of colonialism is
this
and it's not worth it anymore so if so
many people in the palestinian community
say
you know what we'll use the the the the
forces and the idea the same means as i
cannot excellently work
and with that we will kick the israelis
out the only problem what i would say is
that could work against a colonious
power like the british
with a native land is where we are all
standing beautifully here
the problem is when it talks about in
the state of israel
they aren't colonists
the british could go back to britain the
zionist when what they call home
is sion is what every jew has prayed for
for the two last
let me put it to you a different way
everyone justifies their colonism in a
different way
sorry america they have a concept called
manifest destiny and by the way almost
every president has believed in manifest
destiny and westwood expansion
go and research it if you don't believe
me the point of the matter is this the
british empire
did have their own set of justifications
for going into lands and colonizing them
and this i'm saying just because you
have a different set of justifications
it does not mean
that it's not what it is and it's called
colonialism
the point is this and let's put it this
way on this point muhammad no
no no no no you're going to agree that
100 to disagree
okay i'll tell you why we're going to do
that fine because we are conflating now
something called zionism and judaism as
well
and judaism i can't agree that you
should ever be able to touch for a
simple reason
because you say this seeing the hope for
zion
not just i pray for it every day i pray
for it in a peaceful way and an utopia
where we'll be able to live together and
the temple will be built where it was
built before
al-aqsa will be built there
but it will be a place of prayer so you
have to destroy that no
no no no no destroying episodes of
praise
it will work in a way that i'm i'm not
god i've never done anything i haven't
created the world
i just about know when i get up in the
morning what time i'm going to go to bed
i've got no idea how it's going to
happen maybe if we talk we might come to
some idea
but there's going to be a place for all
mankind muslim brothers and jewish
brothers and christian brothers
hindus and sikhs will be able to pray
all will be able to pray
in that place now and disagree we don't
want to pray
but i said i'll tell you putting it from
my i tell you why from a jewish
perspective i'll put the full stop
at that point because for me that is
when you are crossing into my religion
where you have yes oh yes let me
question you don't mind if let me
just let me cross more about that i got
the right let's say no no sorry let me
let me cross more let me cross more into
your religion the problem is always has
been religion actually do you always
agree let me tell you why
i disagree because let me let me tell
you how there's a lot of similarities
between us but one of them is not
our conception of race there's not one
verse in the old testament that even
condemns racism
in fact let me tell you something with
all due respect the old testament the
hebrew bible
is for all intents and purposes i would
argue
you can derive from it an inference of
racism
when you're talking about god repenting
now please let me finish let me finish
let me let me finish let me finish when
you talk about god repenting to israel
when you talk about the distinction
between gentiles and jews we cannot
pretend
to avoid this theological set of
justifications
you do believe that you are in a
hierarchy with other races and you do
believe
that you are at the top of the hierarchy
this is a difference between us
yeah you have spoken and we're going to
defend it yeah go ahead tell you all
right
sorry to tell you you are wrong okay but
the simple fact is as follows go ahead
that means is
judaism is not a race it's not a
religion i was mentioned to you in the
past
there are many contexts what makes what
makes the jewish people
as a jewish community point number two
so it's not just the race because you
couldn't
you could convert into judaism even if i
spoke to many muslim brothers you've
never heard of it but you convert into
judaism i wouldn't advise it to anyone
but it's a fact so it can't be erased
yeah number one because it's tough and
number two is that's where we
theologically differ
because muslims believe i'll tell you
why yeah that the only way
to serve god the only way to go into
paradise whatever it is
is to accept islam and that's the way
forward
because god in your perspective as you
would call it allah
came for all the people of the world yes
to accept it through
the quran and that's the way into
paradise now the jewish perspective
just finished my sentence of course that
means this from the jewish perspective
is
it's not it's not it's not that
the jewish on a hierarchy and the rest
of the world is here
it is we all serve god just in a
different way okay that means
you don't have to become jewish let me
ask you a question
you're more knowledgeable than me and
hebrew now before you leave no no you
can't just do this every time you say
let's go go
calm down this is this is this is
transformative stuff please
yeah this is whatever you've got to do
this is more important okay
okay let me tell you no no no please
let's not dictate things to each other
look here's the point is this guys
i listen listen uh aaron
do you believe that there is a
theological difference
in you and me because of the fact that
you're jewish and what is that
theological difference if there is one
because of the ethnicity i believe there
is no theological difference
in the way what we believe in god no no
difference
between people is that i believe that
all people can serve god
in their own way okay and i don't
believe like muslims that you have to
convert to judy that you save god
yes now and the end result is do muslims
and jews you reach paradise
the answer simple question is yes it's
not creed
fight fights i accept that from you
you're basically opening
uh and kind of open to your open theism
obviously is it no it's okay
as long as you yeah there are battles
that's basically absolutely not true
what i'm gonna do to you right now is
accept what you've just said
okay if you listen to what i said is
that it can be inferred in that way i
didn't say that it
is the only interference that is the
misconception
that's you know you
here's what i'm trying to say look you
would agree with me that
first i totally accept your uh i'm not
going to force my
ex to jesus on you you have your own
ability and your father major scholar
by being muslims i respect that so
there's no reason to be a jew whatever
no problem
i'm saying that despite that being the
case the fact that there have been
theological
uh justifications using ethnicity is
still
current okay so for example if you said
to me look
i and the majority of muslims don't
believe in terrorism we look at the
quran and we
accept that however there are some group
of people that look at the quran
and justify terrorism from it we have to
accept that that exists so that we can
deal with that
you must accept the fact that there are
a lot of people in israel
who are hurried jews orthodox jews who
use
the bible or the hebrew old testament in
order to make a case
for a racial case for the superiority of
the jewish people you might not be one
of them what do you mean as the state of
israel no no as the superiors of the
jews people in general that
the jews and the gentiles are separate
and that the jews the jewish class is
higher than the gentiles there are some
people who say that you're not one of
those
i will know about that i i say it's a
misconception of understanding the
language and the way it's spoken and i
agree
with your jobs thanks brother but let me
just keep it give me two minutes two
minutes
condemn
is this the reason why i mentioned by
the way urgent and the fact that they
became part of the lucid party and
it's because we want to we want to show
you talk about how how much you circle
backwards
we circle backwards to the inception of
the state of israel and we realize
that you have literal terrorist
organizations accepted as such by the
way
by the british by the americans by the
u.n by everyone the international
community like urgon
being absorbed into what is now the
liquid luca party
who of course netanyahu leads which
leads the point being is this when when
israel points to finger hamas they have
to look at their own beginnings
hamas had no has no different
they both believe in a one state
solution let's be honest both of them
believe
that it might work listen together the
the difference between the two is just
tactics and
capabilities that's what you need to
understand but the difference is one is
a group
which is being condemned uh
internationally and the other one is a
state which is being funded by the
americans so we talk later on
yeah all right thank you thank you